[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis bekommen an diesem montagabend
für den sport ist norbert lehmann im
studio gutendorf von mir auch diese neue
woche steht im zeichen des ukraine
krieges
kämpfen ukrainische großstädte die
hauptstadt kiew wird immer mehr zum ziel
der russischen angriffe
militärischer eingreiftruppe der eu
deutschland will im ersten jahr den kern
der neuen einheit stellen
und keine hoffnung auf überlebende in
china ist ein passagierflugzeug mit 132
menschen an bord abgestürzt
mit odessa rückt jetzt eine weitere
strategisch wichtige stadt in den fokus
der russischen truppen am morgen hat es
einen ersten angriff auf einen vorort
der hafenstadt gegeben unsere
korrespondentin ist in odessa wir
sprechen gleich mit ihr und auch auf
kiew nehmen die angriffe zu in der
hauptstadt gilt daher von dieser stunde
an bis mittwochmorgen eine
ausgangssperre ein bericht von nina
kurschilgen und volker dutschek
diese frisch gebackene mutter stillt in
einem käfer bunker ihr drei tage altes
baby sie konnten sich rechtzeitig in
sicherheit bringen bevor die bomben
einschlugen ein einkaufszentrum und ein
angrenzendes hochhausen kiew komplett
zerstört
überwachungskameras filmten den
einschlag bevor helfer hin zu allen um
so viele menschen wie noch irgend
möglich lebend aus den trümmern zu
retten
so schaut euch an was hier los ist das
ist ein einkaufszentrum freunde schaut
euch diese hölle an
präsident selensky appelliert an die eu
und deutschland
ihr deutschen habt doch macht europa hat
doch macht schließt für russland alle
häfen liefert keine waren mehr an sie
nutzt keine russische energie mehr macht
druck dass russland die ukraine verlässt
die vielen toten es bleibt kaum zeit sie
würdevoll zu beerdigen
auf dem völlig zerstörten hauptfriedhof
von kiew tragen soldaten alexander zu
grabe weit weg von seiner familie
wir wollten alexander besonders ehren
weil seine familie im belagerten
mariupol ist wie erreichen sie nicht um
ihnen zu sagen dass ihr sohn tot ist in
kiew und sieben anderen städten sollte
es heute flucht korridore geben für
mario pohl galt das aber wohl nicht hier
begraben sie freunde nachbarn fremde
notdürftig am straßenrand
dabei geht der beschuss unvermindert
weiter mehr als 80 prozent der wohnungen
sollen zerstört sein nun auch diese
schule in der rund 400 menschen schutz
gesucht haben sollen
beschuss auch in der seehafenstadt
ressort
bei einer friedlichen demonstration rund
um den freiheitsplatz fallen schüsse
granaten explodieren es gibt viele
verletzte und
erstmals wird auch odessa angegriffen
russische kriegsschiffe sollen die
hafenstadt am schwarzen meer
bombardieren
26 tage krieg in der ukraine
laut un menschenrechtskommissar sind 925
zivilisten getötet worden in
wirklichkeit ist die zahl der opfer
sicherlich viel höher und
in odessa ist für uns katrin eigendorf
kathrin wie ist die situation jetzt
gerade bei ihm
im moment ist es still es ist ja schon
spät abends aber heute morgen hat es
einen angriff der russischen marine auf
mario pohl gegeben wir haben selber vor
ort uns ein bild davon gemacht da sind
mehrere häuser zerstört worden zum glück
ist niemand verletzt gekommen verletzt
worden oder ums leben gekommen aber man
rätselt hier natürlich ob das der
auftakt ist zu weiteren angriffen auf
die stadt es ist ja schon so dass 100
kilometer von hier eine russische
panzerkolonne auf die stadt unterwegs
war die aufgehalten werden konnte und es
auch schon luftangriffe gegeben hat und
es ist für die russen ein strategisch
ungemein wichtiges ziel es ist die
drittgrößte stadt der ukraine die
wichtigste hafenstadt und deswegen geht
man hier davon aus dass möglicherweise
auch deshalb bald von russen eingenommen
werden könnte aber auch hier ist die
bevölkerung bereit widerstand zu leisten
man bereitet sich wirklich darauf vor
keiner will die weichen die ganze stadt
ist voller barrikaden das ist die
situation heute in odessa vielen dank
für ihre eindrücke aus odessa kathan ein
dorf und
eines der opfer dieses krieges ist der
holocaust überlebende boris romanenko er
wurde bei einem bombenangriff auf seine
wohnung in kharkiv getötet der
96-jährige hatte vier
konzentrationslager überlebt und sich
dafür eingesetzt dass die verbrechen im
nationalsozialismus nicht in
vergessenheit geraten romanenko war
vizepräsident des internationalen
komitees buchenwald dora
in russland ist es schwer informationen
über den krieg zu bekommen der dort noch
nicht einmal so genannt werden darf
jetzt hat ein russisches gericht
facebook und instagram verboten die
beiden online netzwerke seien
extremistisch so die begründung fragen
wir nach bei christian semmeln moskau
christian was hat es mit dieser
entscheidung auf sich
ja das bedeutet im kern auf jeden fall
dass die zensur hier in russland weiter
voranschreitet dass das verbot jetzt so
kam das war jetzt nicht wirklich
überraschend die dienste waren schon
seit anfang märz verboten aber jetzt
eben das urteil und die einstufung als
extremistisch russland wirft facebook
vor dass sich das netzwerk gegen
russland und gegen seine streitkräfte
stellt wer jetzt hier weiter versuchen
will diese netzwerke zu nutzen der kann
das tun zum beispiel über vpn anbieter
das sind die downloadzahlen in den
app-stores der mobilfunkanbieter die
sind nach oben geschnellt und steigen
auch weiter aber das nutzt eben nicht
jeder und die guten anbieter die sind
eben auch teuer vor allem instagram ist
bei den russinnen und russen sehr
beliebt und das heißt von der
staatsanwaltschaft dass die nutzung dass
man sich da jetzt erstmal nicht strafbar
machen werde ob das so bleibt das wenn
wir natürlich weiter beobachten aber
eines können wir jetzt schon feststellen
russland im märz 2022 heißt kein twitter
kein facebook und kein ins meer
einschätzung aus moskau dankeschön
christian sen
angesichts des krieges rechnet die
bundesaußenminister in in der eu mit
acht millionen geflüchteten aus der
ukraine
sie schlug eine solidarische luftbrücke
vor um die menschen in der eu und auch
in die usa zu verteilen berbalk ist
derzeit in brüssel beim treffen der eu
außen und verteidigungsministerin und
minister sie beraten über weitere
sanktionen gegen moskau und sie
beschlossen eine neue militärische
eingreiftruppe ab 20 25
die einzelheiten von anne gellinek
bislang kamen sie noch nie zum einsatz
die sogenannten eu battlegroups
multinationale kampftruppen hier bei
einer übung mal fehlten soldaten mal
wurde gestritten wo sie hingeschickt
werden könnten das soll sich nun ändern
eine neue eu eingreiftruppe mit bis zu
5000 soldaten gerade beschlossen von den
eu außen und verteidigungsministern
deutschland kündigt mehr engagement an
ich werde heute den kolleginnen und
kollegen anbieten dass das militärische
herzstück die schnelle eingreiftruppe im
jahr 2025 dann für ein jahr von
deutschland gestellt werden kann
deutsche soldaten sollen das kommando
und einen gefechts verband der neuen eu
eingreiftruppe stellen der vorschlag
berlins ist auch der versuch bei einem
anderen thema aus der defensive zu
kommen nämlich bei der frage was könnten
die nächsten europäischen sanktionen
seien
europa darf jetzt nicht den eindruck von
erschöpfung erwecken solange der krieg
nicht zu ende ist wir dürfen nicht
sanktionswürdig
immer stärker rückt ein importstopp von
russischem öl und gas ins blickfeld um
putins krieg nicht weiter zu finanzieren
rx stents wenn man sich das ausmaß der
zerstörung in der ukraine ansieht dann
finde ich es sehr schwierig um
sanktionen im energie sektor
herumzukommen das betrifft besonders öl
und kohle
deutschland will seine militärhilfe
entscheidend aufstocken ein energie
embargo aber lehnt berlin weiterhin ab
und in deutschland geht die debatte um
den richtigen umgang mit den
geflüchteten menschen weiter viele
stimmen fordern ein national gipfel um
etwa die verteilung zu regeln ein teil
der bisher laut un 34 millionen
geflüchteten sucht in westeuropa schutz
vor krieg und gewalt die bundespolizei
zählte bisher gut
225.000 schutzsuchende über die großen
herausforderungen für bund länder und
kommunen sylvia bleßmann und nils
schneider
mit circa 10.000 geflüchteten menschen
täglich rechnen sie hier am ukraine
ankunfts zentrum im ehemaligen flughafen
tegel alle die berlin erreichen sollen
sie begrüßt versorgt und als schutz
suchende erfasst werden ein ankunfts tor
von dem aus die menschen dann zügig in
alle anderen bundesländer verteilt
werden sollen
wir gehen im moment in vorleistung dafür
wir haben im moment noch keine klarheit
welcher teil vom bund erstattet wird
eins ist aber klar es muss ein teil auch
vom bund übernommen werden
bundeswehrsoldaten helfen hier noch bis
ende märz dann soll berlin mit eigenem
personal den ansturm bewältigen
im verteilzentrum fällt die entscheidung
wer in der stadt bleiben kann und wer
nur kurz übernachtet um dann weiter zu
reisen die logistik ist aktuell das
größte problem die busse zur passenden
zeit in die richtige stadt zu bekommen
das müsse besser koordiniert werden ein
bundeseinheitliches krisen management
fordert der thüringische
ministerpräsident wir erleben zurzeit
noch dass es sehr holprig ist und ich
kann da nur an den bund appellieren
endlich in die verantwortung zu gehen
das muss der bund in die hand nehmen
kommunen melden täglich ihre freien
bettenkapazitäten nach berlin und
kontingente in hotels oder messehallen
aus denn durch zuweisung werden nun
tausende vor allem frauen und kinder in
viele städte kommen das geld muss von
bund und ländern kommen das brauchen wir
dauerhaft und wir brauchen die
unterstützung bei der integration in den
arbeitsmarkt wegen des nicht abreißenden
flüchtlingsstroms freuen bund und länder
bis zum 7 april einen plan vorlegen der
zumindest finanziell klarheit bringen
soll
wenn sie geflüchteten helfen wollen auch
in der ukraine können sie geld spenden
zb dem aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de
oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
die abhängigkeit von russischer energie
verringern das ist ein ziel der
bundesregierung auf der suche nach neuen
quellen verhandelt sie nun auch mit
staaten deren politisches system berlin
eigentlich kritisch sieht
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck war
heute in den vereinigten arabischen
emiraten in abu dhabi schloss der
kooperationsabkommen zur wasserstoff
nutzung ab mit katar hatte habe zuvor
eine energiepartnerschaft vereinbart vor
allem für flüssiggas
und direkt nach dieser heute sendung
sehen sie ein zdf spezial zum krieg in
der ukraine und in unserer app haben wir
weitere hintergründe im live-blog
behalten wir die aktuellen entwicklungen
für sie im blick
schauen wir jetzt auf weitere themen des
tages die krankenkassen warnen eine
krone impfpflicht sei derzeit kaum
umzusetzen
der vorgesehene zeitrahmen sei zu eng um
alle 60 millionen versicherten
anzuschreiben dafür gebe es nicht mal
genug papier denn das sei gerade knapp
hieß es in einer anhörung im bundestag
die aktuellen corona zahl binnen 24
stunden registrierte das
robert-koch-institut
92 1314 neuinfektionen das sind 64
weniger als vergangenen montag 13
todesfall äckern dazu die sieben tage
incident steigt wieder leicht auf etwa
1700 14
die zahlen also nach wie vor hoch die
home office pflicht ist aber mit beginn
der neuen arbeitswoche ausgelaufen heißt
die firma kam bei der hin dass arbeiten
von zu hause ermöglichen muss es aber
nicht überhaupt liegt jetzt die
verantwortung für die korona schutz der
mitarbeitenden in den händen der
betriebe andrea meuser mit dem aktuellen
stand
lippenstift augenfarbe und make-up dass
sie farbe und textur mal im video
schalten besprechen und beurteilen
würden hätte sich bei diesem
kosmetikhersteller in frankfurt vor
jahren niemand träumen lassen seit
corona aber arbeiten die meisten
kolleginnen von zu hause nur ganz wenige
kommen ins büro ich bin noch nicht so
lange da ich noch in der
einarbeitungsphase und gerade das auch
für mich wichtig im austausch mit meinen
kolleginnen zusammen jetzt aber könnten
theoretisch alle 600 mitarbeiterinnen
wieder ins büro kommen die dreijährige
gilt nicht mehr und ob sie masken und
einen test pro woche zur verfügung
stellen sollen die arbeitgeber selbst
entscheiden impfen während der
arbeitszeit ist erlaubt wir können das
sagen die arbeitgeber treibt die
infektionszahlen hoch warnen die
gewerkschaften und wir müssen das
infektionsgeschehen am arbeitsplatz so
gut wie möglich unter kontrolle halten
und da hat sich das home office in der
vergangenheit bewährt ich glaube dass
die neuen regeln uns individuellere
zielgerichtetere und auch vernünftigere
angemessenere maßnahmen für den
gesundheitsschutz nicht nur bei corona
liefern abstand einhalten schutz
gewährleisten und hygiene konzepte
anpassen komplizierte aufgabe bei der
firma kunst nova lösen sie das mit einer
betriebsvereinbarung nach den
osterferien würden wir uns wünschen dass
wir doch alle wieder regelmäßig ein paar
tage die woche im büro sind gerade die
mittleren tage die woche damit wir
einfach auch ein bisschen überlappende
anwesenheit haben nach dem jetzigen
stand sind die regeln bis zum 25 mai
befristet dann wird die lage erneut
beurteilt
im zusammenhang mit der korona pandemie
werden immer wieder straftaten verübt
für entsetzen sorgte der mord an einem
20 jährigen tankstellenmitarbeiter im
september vergangenen jahres in idar
oberstein er hatte einen kunden auf die
masken pflicht aufmerksam gemacht dieser
hat ihn dann erschossen über den
prozessauftakt vor dem landgericht bad
kreuznach berichtet christopher heize
die tat die mario n vorgeworfen wird hat
bundesweit für entsetzen gesorgt und zu
diskussionen über eine radikalisierung
der korona leugner szene geführt im
verlauf des prozesses wie sich der
angeklagte dazu äußern der angeklagte
will unbedingt angaben machen zur sache
er bereut die tat gesteht auch die tat
selbst an dieser tankstelle in idar
oberstein wurde der student alexander w
beim kassieren erschossen die
überwachungskamera zeigt mario m am 18
september beim bier kaufen im
verkaufsraum ohne mund nasenschutz als
alexander wie ihn auf die masken pflicht
hinweist verlässt er damals 49-jährige
die tankstelle anderthalb stunden später
kommt er zurück zunächst mit
aufgesetztem und nasenschutz doch an der
kasse zieht er die maske bewusst runter
der streit um die masten pflicht
eskaliert mit einem revolver soll mario
an dem 20-jährigen dann in den kopf
geschossen haben auf twitter hatte der
angeklagte schon lange zuvor
verschwörungstheoretiker inhalte geteilt
und drohungen ausgestoßen man sieht eben
schon das lange vor der tat recht
negative verbreitet wurden eine gewisse
gewalt affinität sich auch in den social
media profilen gezeigt hat und dass das
ganze nicht erst mit der panini
angefangen hat der 50 jährige mario ende
ist auch wegen unerlaubten
waffenbesitzes angeklagt
voraussichtlich mitte mai soll das
urteil verkündet werden
im sich jenas ist ein passagierflugzeug
abgestürzt mit
132 menschen an bord kurz vor gestürzt
es plötzlich und aus großer höhe zu
boden niemand kann das überlebt haben
christoph des 3
kreisrund frisst sich das feuer durch
den wald keine spuren einer notlandung
sondern eine katastrophe die die
ermittler bislang ratlos macht denn
ziemlich sicher ist die boeing 737 fast
senkrecht wie ein stein abgestürzt zwei
videos zeigen dass und ein augenzeuge
bestätigt dabei gab es weder rauch noch
feuer die maschine war in einem stück
helfer suchen in dem abgelegenen
waldgebiet nach trümmerteilen und opfern
123 passagiere und 9
besatzungsmitglieder ohne chance der
aufprall habe die boeing komplett
zerstört heißt es über die letzten
momente des flugs weiß man bisher so
viel 8800 meter höhe alles normal als
die maschine plötzlich abrupt ab sagt
drei minuten sturzflug aber mittendrin
das ergaben die flugdaten kurz einen
moment als habe jemand vergeblich
versucht die maschine abzufangen der
experte ließ das so es kann in
irgendeiner weise menschliche ursachen
haben das heißt dass die piloten nicht
mehr handlungsfähig waren sei es dass an
bord versucht irgendwie die piloten
auszuschalten oder auf der anderen seite
natürlich probleme mit dem flugzeug
strukturelle probleme materielle
probleme so oder so ordnete china ist
ein airlines an alle boeing 737 der
fluggesellschaft bleiben vorerst am
boden bis man mehr weiß über ein unglück
das beobachter vor allem so beschreiben
sehr rätselhaft extrem ungewöhnlich
sie sind brutal und skrupellos ermordet
worden dabei verdienten polizistinnen
und polizisten die tag für tag ihr leben
für die sicherheit der bevölkerung
riskierten schutz und respekt das sagte
bundesinnenminister heute bei der
offiziellen gedenkfeier für die
polizistin und ihren kollegen die ende
januar bei einer verkehrskontrolle
erschossen wurde am ende der trauerfeier
weiße luftballons für die toten ein 38
jähriger steht unter mordverdacht die
ermittelnden gehen davon aus dass damit
will der rai vertuscht werden sollte
hier kommt zum sport zum fußball norbert
und zum traditionsreichen spitzenspiel
der spanischen jaja der clasico real
madrid gegen den fc barcelona
ja und da haben die königlichen eine
schmerzhafte 0 2 4-heimniederlage gegen
den erz rivalen einstecken müssen zwei
basler tore gingen aufs konto des ex
dortmunders obermann es läuft wieder
beim fc barcelona dank trainer charly
die katalanen führen die königlichen vor
co produktion zweier ex dortmunder der
starke dembelé bedient aubameyang
führung in der 29 minute sturmlauf der
gäste das zweite tor erzielte per kopf
es ist der halbzeitstand und jetzt
geht's einfach in die andere richtung
zwei minuten gespielt hatte obermaier
young für andres zum dritten das ist ein
desaster für die einen und ein fest für
die anderen und ein besonderer spaß für
ihn pierre emerick aubameyang noch nie
war ein spieler in seinen ersten clasico
an drei toren beteiligt vier zu null der
fc barcelona ist wieder da auch dank des
ex dortmunders der american
[Applaus]
fußball bundesliga das eins zu eins der
dortmunder gestern abend in köln
marius wolf hatte den bvd bvb in der
achten minute in führung gebracht den
ausgleich erzielte sebastian anders sind
in der 36 minute dortmund nun wieder mit
sechs punkten abstand auf tabellenführer
bayern borussias künftiger sportdirektor
sebastian kehl hat den kampf um die
meisterschaft abgehakt
alle tore alle highlights des spieltages
zu sehen bei uns auf zdf heute.de und in
der heute
ex tennis star boris becker muss sich
seit heute vor einem londoner gericht
verantworten ihm wird vorgeworfen in
seinem insolvenzverfahren vermögenswerte
und besitztümer in seinen angaben
unterschlagen und informationspflicht
nicht eingehalten zu haben ihm drohen
bis zu sieben jahre haft becker weist
die vorwürfe zurück
weltrekord im stabhochsprung durch
überflieger armand geplant ist bei der
hallen wm in belgrad springt er im
dritten versuch sechs meter 20 und
verbessert damit seinen eigenen
weltrekord den er vor zwei wochen an
gleicher stelle aufgestellt hatte um
einen zentimeter
das was vom sport dankeschön rabatt
sonnig und nach kalten nächten wird es
oft schon war so wird das wetter in
dieser woche mehr gleich von katja
horneffer das heute journal gibt es um
21 50 mit christian sievers um bleiben
sie jetzt dran für ein zdf spezial zum
ukraine krieg auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend show am wochenende gab es
hohen luftdruck und denner haben einige
von ihnen ein paar schneeflocken gesehen
die hingen zusammen mit diesem kleinen
kaltluft tropfen diesen wolken wirbel
der weitergezogen ist über die nordsee
und inzwischen schon norwegen erreicht
hat heute war von diesem kaltluft
tropfen gar nichts mehr zu merken bei
uns es gab nämlich doch zumeist
strahlenden sonnenschein und die
temperaturen stiegen auf 10 grad an der
ostsee und bis auf 19 grad am
niederrhein jetzt in der nacht wird
zeigt kalt im osten sinken die werte auf
0 bis -5 grad im westen bleibt es bei
sechs bis null grad milder dazu ist es
meist klar allenfalls am alpenrand gibt
es vielleicht mal ein paar nebelfelder
und einige wolken im nordwesten die sich
dort auch morgen über tag noch mal
zeigen können sonst aber strahlt die
sonne es gibt eine hohe waldbrandgefahr
hier im nordosten und im süden auch eine
hohe sonnenbrandgefahr
bereits nach 30 minuten können sie
ungeschützt einen sonnenbrand davon
tragen die temperaturen morgen die ganz
ähnliche heute zwischen 12 grad an der
ostsee und 20 grad am niederrhein und in
den nächsten tagen geht es ganz ähnlich
weiter der wind allerdings dreht
allmählich auf nördliche richtungen
guten abend